[Music]
hello everyone
welcome my name is julianne i'm with the
nba admissions office for the stanford
graduate school of business
i'm so thrilled that you're joining us
today i'll be your host today in
moderator um but the main focus is
really going to be talking to
our alumni um who are all from
south america so you'll get a really a
really great perspective
i'm now going to move into our panelists
so
i've got their information up here on
the screen
um and i'd like each of our panelists to
introduce yourselves as you can so maybe
we can just
move starting with sofia and move across
the chart
um if you would include your name where
you're from
class year and then maybe your favorite
experience whether it's academic or
extracurricular from the gsb that comes
top of mind and sophia i just put you on
the spot to think of your memory but if
there's something that comes top of mind
that
um stands out to you as a really
positive experience of the gsb
let's start with her um hi everybody um
i just
saw there's a 182 people connected so
it's a very big crowd well my name is
sophia
i'm mba class of 2008
i'm from argentina my undergrad i did my
undergrad in university of pennsylvania
in wharton
and before the mba i did investment
banking
after that i did invest in banking and
also
private equity and for the past um six
years or so i've been working at riva
which is a family-owned construction
business in argentina
and in terms of the gsb the overall
experience is amazing
um i think in terms of friendships and
relationships that's one of the
one that's you know um one thing i would
highlight
um julian didn't give me a lot of time
to think about it
so um that's what i'd like to highlight
and also i graduated i'm i'm the oldest
in the panel so i think it probably
changes throughout the years what do you
what do you value the
can i most yes thank you hi this
is ignacio rupix i am a class of 2009
i did my undergrad in buenos aires in
argentina i lived in here
in argentina as well all my background
was in corporate finance
in industrial companies i wanted to the
the mba to switch into management
consulting
and i i make it i made it happen so i
have been working with mckinsey for the
last
12 years i am a partner based in the
buenos aires office
serving clients all over latin america
these days on a remote mode as you can
imagine
one nice memory that i always
have with me it's uh it's it's a close
it's a class that probably you all know
it's touchy feely
it has a more formal name called
interpersonal dynamics
but one of the activities into that
class is to have and
spend a weekend inside a house with all
your classmates from from
from your learning group and it's a very
intense and
very personal moment of sharing
and and a lot of group dynamics that the
the teachers put together so i remember
that weekend
as a very inspiring one and a
a situation where i learned a lot from
from my classmates
who were from like very different
backgrounds
compared to mine so that that's a nice
memory i have from the gsb
that looks like daniella i don't know if
she's on yet but let me move over to you
jose yes perfect hi everybody
jose gravel here i am from peru
i'm back in lima before stanford i was
doing investment banking primarily
in peru and also had a short stash in
new york
and after the mba i remained in banking
i i spent almost two years in san
francisco and then
moved back to lima and i currently work
for
jp morgan in terms of experiences i
could
you know take the whole panel to share
experiences but but in addition to
to amazing anecdotes and friendships
i ran into steve jobs one day on my way
to campus
it was it was a bit embarrassing because
i had a blackberry so i took a picture
to the guy who invented the iphone using
my my blackberry and
and the other good anecdote is i found
out years later that the house where i
spent my second year
is the one where mark zuckerberg founded
facebook so so
two good things related to the gsp
experience
jose we shared the same house true
true one year apart yes
well i guess it's my turn um i'm luca
salamonic
i'm chilean i'm an mba class of 2020. so
recently graduated
my undergrad was was in chile in
university academica
and then i did five years of investment
banking also jp morgan
um most of them being in santiago but
also
kind of a short stint in new york which
is probably the same as jose had
um and yeah after gsb
and during the summer actually i joined
axel kr which is a
growth equity private equity firm
focused on technology investments
um around the world and into latin
america
and i've been doing that actually for
the summer also
during 2020 on a part-time role and
full-time starting last month
regarding my favorite gsb experience i
mean
it's it's pretty fresh and it's probably
too too too many to recount
but one that comes into my mind is we
have we had a
global study tree which is one of the
requirements to to graduate actually uh
in new zealand and
it doesn't matter a reason but our tour
guide for two days was the former prime
minister of new zealand so
actually uh he was doing the bus
during the whole time telling us the
story of the country and actually
explaining us everything
that was going on while we were
traveling in the country
and then we spent barbecues at his place
and
he was just extremely friendly with us
and having having a
having a tour guide which is basically
the former prime minister is
is something that i wasn't expecting
before coming to the gsb
and similar to the encounters with steve
jobs and whatnot like
you're going to experience many of those
things you wouldn't expect it to
experience before
thank you all um i'm going to throw a
couple questions
out there to start us off i know there's
some questions coming in through q and a
which is great but
let's uh we'll start maybe um ignacio
and
luca i'm going to start with you now so
you mentioned a class that was your
favorite and lucas since you just
recently finished i'd like to hear um
what
academic experience um whether it was a
class a professor or
project which was your favorite one and
this is you know we're really
trying to understand how stamper might
expand someone's mindset and help them
grow academically
um so luca and ignacio if you can take
that question
that's right okay i can start
uh there is a class uh it's called
patch to power by michael pfeffer it's a
professor he has written a lot of books
and i
i still remember the class because the
topic is quite unique
it's not a traditional angle it's around
like power dynamics and how those
power dynamics play out in the
in any corporate environment and it's
not only the shiny
side of power or interpersonal dynamics
but
probably the other not the chinese which
is around
advancing your agenda trying to
gain an advantage and what i remember
about the class was that
it was very straightforward very direct
very blunt and and it had a lot of
testimonials so i remember we will have
a lot of entrepreneur entrepreneurs and
executives
coming in to the class and share and to
share their experiences
and in some occasions those experiences
were like like positive ones like
steve jobs came in or the ceo of google
came in but in some other instances the
speakers were people who didn't do that
great
who made mistakes and i remember that
that part especially because it's it was
what was like very real to have all
those
experiences from the positives and the
not so positives or the negatives
so that was a very useful and applicable
subject back in time
yeah in my case um
i'd say so i came to gsb with the idea
of
trying to take like zero finance classes
i know that's probably not possible
because you you need to take at least
one as a requirement
but but i was i was almost able to
achieve that
that objective um and i i took mostly
entrepreneurship computer science
and soft skill classes one of them
called um
formation of new ventures which is
basically a class where they
give you a brief introduction it's like
entrepreneurship 101
but the whole purpose of this class is
to convince you to make the jump to
entrepreneurship
um so the two professors one of them is
the former dean
at the gsb uh they bring this like the
most amazing entrepreneurs
um which which which many of them are
actually uh
graduates from the gsb and the whole
idea is
for you to realize that they're like
normal people that launch it
launched amazing things and how they
went through all those struggles through
a case study approach and it was it was
kind of a
very transformational class because it
makes you realize that whatever you want
to achieve in the future is possible
and that uh normal people and i consider
myself like a normal guy
can can do that through through great
and through like just pursuing it and it
was it was amazing so
founder of doordash founder of trx and
many others who
came through the gsb where they're
presenting their stories and
and talking about their struggles
yeah um so jose and sophia i'm going to
come
to you next um could you talk about how
you've grown
as a leader as a result of your gsb
experience
perfect i i can i can start there
julian so i would say probably you know
the
the most impacting the
the highest impact that the gsb had in
me at least was
not so much on the on the amount of
knowledge that i took out of it but
how i grew as a person and and clearly
at the gsb
you are surrounded by extremely talented
people
many of them are way more talented than
than you
than you are they have you know so much
diversity so
so the main challenge is how to lead
beings
and how to be led by others
and you have to struggle with egos with
conflicting personalities with different
approaches so so i think
at the gsb you're gonna have you know
plenty of
courses that that will shape your
leadership style that will
make you aware of what are your
strengths and weaknesses and also to
interact with other people
to to anticipate situations that you're
gonna find in the work
workplace as a leader so i i would say
i it really transformed me from from a
leadership standpoint
you're gonna have several tools
courses and extracurricular activities
to test your leadership skills and learn
from
from your classmates
yeah i think in terms of following up a
bit on what jose was saying i think
you know 100 of the people you meet at
the gsb are type a personality people so
everybody's gonna be in charge
and make decisions and say you know the
way things need to be done
so um it's interesting to
have to deal with everybody and there's
a lot there's a lot of
group work so it's interesting to learn
how to deal with that
um and come out of it and what
i mean and everybody's leading but in a
different way um
and knowing you know it's important to
know when to step back
step down and when to step up um and i
think that
translates later on um work wise
um i mean
in work depending where you go to work
you'll find more or less type a
personality people but uh it's important
to recognize that
and then to know how to deal with it and
how to um how to manage
situations um okay so we've got a
question
here about um it's actually from victor
and i think it's really thought
provoking
um so when you look back to who you were
as a person
before and after your gsb experience
what would you say change the most and
maybe we'll have one or two of our
panelists answer that question
if it strikes anyone's fancy otherwise i
can call on someone
ignacio i see you smiling you want to
take this
yeah i can take it i can take it uh of
course that it
for each of us it's a different story
but but for me uh uh i think
uh the gsb helped me become
a more diverse persona
so as to say because i had the
opportunity
to really explore many many things while
at the gsb
i i have a very traditional background
in corporate finance
working for companies so um
but i took advantage of the gsb to
attend classes
in other schools to attend
talks with like people from all walks of
life
i joined the entrepreneurship club and
visited
many startups not because i wanted to
to create a startup after the gsb but
rather because i wanted to see how it's
like
to be an entrepreneur i have your own
company
i did a class on on dynamics of the wine
industry
just because i wanted to learn about
that industry which was important in
argentina but also
because i wanted to have fun showing us
and and i
ended up traveling in around 40
countries from
in those years considering all the
summer breaks and then
three months off that we took with some
classmates
to travel across asia and russia so
in a sense i think that i took advantage
of
like the platform that the gsb provides
to explore like many many interests and
that stay with me
in different dimensions not necessarily
like professionally speaking
but today i i'm a big fan of wine
tasting
and with my wife we have been traveling
in around 100 countries
so it's uh those passions that we
ignited at the gsb stay with me in a
different
role in my life so that could be
an experience
um luca could you talk a little bit
about the
entrepreneur entrepreneurial community
and different
resources or clubs that might have been
available for folks interested in
entrepreneurship
sure thing um so first of all i mean
you you you may know that that the gsb
is
is one of the schools which is which is
characterized by a very strong
entrepreneurial community
and both on the side of of raising money
of getting contacts with
with potential venture firms that would
sponsor your your
your endeavor as well as with resources
to be able to operate that from the
ground up
um and i came to the gsp with the idea
of
of of trying out the the the like
entrepreneurial or entrepreneurship and
i think it was amazing from the side of
so there's several classes which are
100 focus on entrepreneurship one of
them which
which i told you before was formation
revengers
which is more of a case study approach
so it's also multi-disciplinary
there's another one which is very
popular which you need to apply it for
is called startup garage and i also did
that one
where you basically go through the whole
like neat finding process to be able to
create an idea from scratch based on a
need
and and to and to and to
start looking for something which is
called product market fit which is the
way
where an idea gets demand
and ends up becoming a company or
startup and
it was a really good class there's
there's another class which is connected
to the gsp as well but also
imparted by the engineering school which
is called
lean startup or lean lunch but i think
it's called it's it's very popular as
well and
several gsb classmates take it and you
can see from all those classes like
different uh different students that end
up
creating ventures based on those ideas
and end up getting funding and you
hear several several case studies of of
public companies which started through
those classes which is which is amazing
to hear as well and there's also
different
initiatives which are extracurricular so
it's a
funding uh given to you one by stanford
i think
i don't remember the exact names of of
them because i never pursued one
but but a couple of friends of mine one
one of them is actually chilean he got
probably like 30 50 dollars just
to explore their startup endeavor while
he was at school
and that was like zero equity is just
like we we want to give you the
opportunity to
to start this and and to seek this this
this path that you're looking for and
and it was just amazing like to have
those resources without
one like giving zero percent equity of
your future endeavor
and two just through a powerpoint or an
idea you had and maybe a vision you had
so yeah thank you um sophia maybe you
could take this next one um
could you talk about what some of the
most important or
impactful tools that stanford gave you
to accomplish your post
mba goals
well um i think the stanford network is
probably the most important one um in
terms of post
i mean i had um i'm from argentina but i
had lived in
i did my undergrad in the states and i
worked before
um the nba in the states so i wanted to
go actually to europe afterwards
um and actually getting a job in europe
from stanford is not as easy as it might
it's not
it's not the easiest thing just because
of time zone and just uh the stanford
community
is super strong in the bay area and the
u.s but maybe not that strong outside of
the us
um having said that um when i started
looking for jobs um
in in europe it was fairly easy with the
stanford community the stanford name is
super strong so it opens lots of doors
um and after you know a few and then you
know
years down the road um when i had to
switch jobs
et cetera um i you know it kept us the
stamford name and the stanford community
and everything that kind of scampered
related is something very strong and and
opens lots of doors
and i think that that was definitely one
of the most valuable
tools i got from the mba
jose i'm going to go to you could you
share
um how the gsb may have changed your
view of your home country
and maybe what you could achieve there
in peru well uh
i started seeing lots of similarities
between san francisco and lima both are
next to the ocean both
are super cloudy both are very
warm people but in general other than
those
minor details what i would say is when
when you spend
three years in california because i
stayed for a year working there and then
you come to your country
you come full of you know ideas
initiatives you know a true interest in
improving and raising the bar at your
country and that not only includes
you know when you think about just
upgrading the infrastructure
but just giving back to the community
understanding that you know
you had uh the opportunity of
studying and learning at a fantastic
institution and
now going back to your country to give
back
to to get involved into
take your business to the next level to
you know
support your community locally so so so
i would say i came back to peru after
three years
with with a lot of good ideas to
contribute to the country
uh and um that is
that is something that i would say all
of us who came back to our countries who
could benefit from from from the gsb
experience
um so i think this next question i'm
going to pose to
ignacio um
would you say that stanford was worth
the investment
and did it open up many opportunities
for work or your life
etc well i say absolutely yes
no doubt in fact back in time when i
applied
i obtained a full scholarship full
tuition paid
plus living expenses from another top
usa school and i declined that
because i wanted to attend stanford and
uh
and because it was worth the investment
uh of time and of money it's i always
sort of share the analogy when you are
at least in my case but it may not apply
to everyone but
when you're building your professional
career in your home country or the type
of companies you're working for it's
like running in the
it's a race track with like uh we call
it turismo carretera
in spanish at least in argentina and go
to stanford and when you exit
you suddenly appear with an f1 car in an
f1 race it's up to you how to drive the
car
but you have the chance and you have
access to all those opportunities
that sophia mentioned it's not that you
are gonna have
any special power or it's not that you
will develop any sense of entitlement
but the truth is that will
open a lot of opportunities for you for
you to go and
and capture those those opportunities so
uh in my case i wanted to change
the function i was working on in part
the geography
also the industries and i did change all
three things at the same time
and stanford was a great catalyst
in giving me the confidence that i could
do it
and uh and that for me is the analogy
say we are all doing great in your
professional careers today
that's why we are really considering
applying to stanford in most of the
cases
but i think that stanford allows you to
to think far bigger
and to elevate your game and uh and
that's quite unique
of the ethos of the university
uh luka i'm going to come back to you
you're closest to the application
process
um could you talk about maybe what was
the most challenging part about applying
about applying um
i think the whole application is
challenging i think covet is
probably making it even more challenging
i've heard a bunch of
nightmare stories of how to do the gmat
online etc which
and you have one shot instead of like
three or four that that
many of us could have taken um i think
but like going back to the application
and definitely
thing that took me the most amount of
time was writing the
the essay the famous why what matters
most to you and why
um and and at the end of the day um
it's it's it's a very different essay
from from other schools i applied
to this is an essay that forces you to
do real introspection on everything that
has happened in your life
and why those things have shaped you
into who you are
and i i don't think that anyone has the
crucible
of how to nail that essay so there's
no right or wrong when you write that
essay which makes it
really interesting because at the end of
the day your best shot is just
it's just writing who you truly are and
what you really want to be
and and crossing fingers so that works
out so
the whole uncertainty of not being able
to
optimize that essay because that it
cannot be optimized in any any shape or
form
was probably the hardest part of the
application but also that
the best part of it as well because i
mean i've read that essay
i actually had to read it for a couple
of classmates while i was at gsb
and that's something that we tend to do
as well and some with with some glasses
of wine and whatnot
and and you go back to that essay it's
not just one
a one-off thing that you do when you
never again really like you actually go
back to it
and it needs to be stuff that you're
proud or you you really mean
and not stuff that you think is just
gonna increase your odds to getting into
stanford so
that was probably the most challenging
part but also the best part of it
um so i'm going to go to jose and sophia
for this one
maybe jose will start with you and then
sophia since you attended war and you
might be able to give a different
perspective but
why did you choose the gsb over any
other
business school so
i would say again and i said this before
i
i wasn't a career changer the the mba
wasn't
for me to go from banking to something
different i wanted to stay in finance
to me the mba was about taking myself
out of the comfort zone from a personal
standpoint taking my
my personal skills to the next level so
so i
i found the gsb set of values a sense of
community that i didn't find
anywhere else and clearly going to a
place where you're surrounded by you
know silicon valley and all this
indonesian culture was precisely what i
was lacking
you know the ability of thinking out of
the box to again
take myself out of the comfort zone was
was was something that stanford offered
and that i didn't find
in such a capacity in other schools
again
to me the mba brings you a lot of tools
and knowledge to be a fantastic
professional but
nowadays a lot of that knowledge is
available in other sources i think to me
the mba is about the personal experience
it's about the
relationships you develop the network
the culture you're surrounded by
and that is something where i think
stanford stands out in
a unique way
um well for me um
it was definitely a little it was
definitely about um
getting out of my comfort zone i'd um
i'd spend the last many years in the
east coast
um i had already done kind of a first
jump out of my comfort zone
when i went from argentina to the u.s to
study but after that i spent
um i had already spent eight years in
the east coast um
i did my undergrad there and then i did
four years in new york working
mainly in goldman sachs so going to the
west coast going to stanford was
something new something different
huge change um i had
never been i'd been only once to
california before
um it was it was it was also kind of
getting
more in understanding a bit more about
entrepreneurship about technology uh
which were things that were not
normal to me i used google was was kind
of a a tool but not a company
we had there there was no company behind
it was just a tool i used um
so it was it was experiencing new things
um
and it was i mean that's
maybe why i chose it and also what a
little bit of what i mentioned before
stanford in
in the us is a huge name and it opens
lots of doors
so that was definitely something that i
valued um
and in retrospect it was definitely the
the one of the best choices i made it
was an amazing experience
uh great years great friendships lots of
learning
um it was amazing but um i guess for me
it was it was doing something
different in terms of education in terms
of the what i was living et cetera
and then luca could you talk a little
bit about the career management center
and the role it may have played for
getting an internship
or a job and if there's anything you
think that the career management center
could
improve upon
all right so the career management
center is basically
a division within the gsb that helps you
on recruiting both in terms of summer as
well as
in terms of full time they have
both regional expertise as well as
like vertical expertise in terms of
different industries
and i think it's a really good resource
uh
particularly for internationals and
internationals that are trying to get
jobs into technology consulting in the
u.s
private equity in the us and those
industries were
is a bit harder uh because you you're
basically benchmarked against
and against your benchmark with
americans
and people that are native english
speakers that studied in very
prestigious
american schools and and that we know
that employers will have a bias towards
them
so they help you in a way to position
your profile and to show your strengths
or your relative strengths
as an international to be able to be
competitive
um in in those recruiting processes
so if you ever had the maybe the
inspiration of staying into the us and
working here
not necessarily with your former
employee uh
leveraging on the cmc is actually a
really good source
um and at the end of the day and with
most of the
things at stanford is about how much
time you put into it
so if if bill or whoever
you're having a relationship within the
cmc uh knows that you really want to do
it and you're spending a lot of time on
it
he's going to spend a lot of time on you
if you just send him your resume
and expect him to land you a job at
google it's probably not going to happen
but at the end of the day what i saw
from from all my classmates was that
they
they were really able to to help them
both polishing their wrestleman their
profile and on the other side
helping them on the more structured
recruiting processes which is like big
tech as i said consulting
and big finance and for the more
small things or very specific things
that are not necessarily
just typical recruiting they can help
you like providing
you with a bit of like words of wisdom
and next steps checking those cold
emails that you're probably gonna send
etc etc so
very valuable i think uh in terms of
areas of improvement now that you ask
julian it's probably it's about getting
a bit more of geographical
expertise and be gabled in a way to
portray
a bit better whether they're what are
the benefits of recruiting
internationals in the us
um and getting those relationships as
well
because if not you end up like getting
funneled into
into the more structured like the big
opportunities and you end up like losing
the chance to getting into the more
specific things you may be interested in
but really good resource
okay so we have time for one last
question
um i'm not sure i might pose this to you
then if anyone wants to add anything
feel free
um so question focusing on diversity and
would you
say that and i for alums i would
encourage you to think of you know
now all of the other alums from
different classes you've met
but would you say that stanford values
um
latinos from different backgrounds both
non-white
non-male lgbtq how what would you say
diversity is among your
uh your peers as well as your alumni
community
you know by chance while luca was
talking i was reflecting on on my
experience around diversity at the gsb
and i think that the gsb
back in time i i attended between 2007
and 2009 so that much more than 10 years
ago
back in time the gsb was a pioneer in
diversity
i remember there were a lot of classes
for instance around the uh for women
around interpersonal dynamics or
leadership i attended
one of those classes because i was
dating a gsp
and she invited me to a class with a
hundred ladies
and there were three males and that was
a moment i would always remember because
it was the first time at least in my
life i was
in a group like very different for
myself
and the gsb created those environments
when it was not that common
so in that sense uh
i think that the gsb was was a pioneer
on this topic
and to be honest i never felt any
difference
in in terms of the
the ethnicity or the background of our
people
the latino community it's big at
stanford
in my class it was there were a lot of
mexicans
and also the university does a very good
job
of blending people so in my touchy feely
class
for instance i was with people
who were like gay
jewish latino black
white europeans and and trying to put
together different
ethnic groups as asian and all these
people
came from different backgrounds and that
group was designed on purpose
to have very very different people into
the group so
sharing over a full quarter how do all
these people feel about the same
realities that we face at the university
to me it's quite a unique learning
experience that probably in
50 years ago no one was able to provide
at least
an mba education i know who it is today
but
the the fundamentals were in there
when i attended and probably that has
evolved
so in that sense i think that the usb
it's really cutting edge
to be honest
thank you so i'm going to start closing
this out thank you
all of our panelists for sharing your
experiences
and and sharing your background and
everything answering our questions
i really thank you all for coming today
know you know it's different times
throughout the world wherever you are
but thank you for making time
to hear about us and learning about the
gsb
i hope you've been inspired by
everything you've heard today and
i do hope we'll see you at future events
thank you all so much for your time and
for your interest in
stanford and best of luck to those of
you who are applying in the next year or
so
thanks for joining